what is Lumber Liquidators doing today
my friend well there's a delay in the
opening of trading it has not yet begun
to trade at 30 1055 what we do know is
that it is expected to be a big loser
once trading does begin because in the
pre-market Lumber Liquidators tumbled to
under thirty nine dollars so that's a
pretty good indication right there off
25% 3891 was the latest price now as you
mentioned 60 minutes ran at that story
last night that showed the company sold
illegal flooring the company of course
has responded by saying that they comply
with applicable regulations regarding
their products and as well in California
which is a most stringent they also make
the point that these attacks are driven
by small group of short selling
investors if you look at the short
interest in this company thirty-three
percent of float which is shares
available for trading that is up from
about eleven percent in July so
certainly the Bears have gotten a lot
more active when it comes to lumber
liquidators of late one thing that we
should mention here is that the stock
has already tumbled quite a bit last
week down twenty four percent going from
$68 to almost $52 after the CEO had
already indicated that an upcoming 60
minutes story would put the company in
an unfavorable light David Strasser says
this is a bad accusation that will
probably hurt sales momentum it could
shave 10 to 13 cents off earnings per
share but it's already reflected he sets
in today's opening price of about forty
dollars